SAARIK KALIA: OK.
Hi.
So my name is
Saarik, and I'm going
to be talking today about how
we can use the 21 centimeter
hydrogen line to determine
the galactic rotation
curve and some of the structure
of the Milky Way galaxy.
So first off, why do we care
about galactic rotation curves?
So basically rotation speed
can tell us about mass.
We know this from simple
Newtonian mechanics.
If you have a planet
going around a sun,
then its velocity is given by
this equation, where M here
is the mass of the sun.
In our case, since we're
working with a galaxy,
we have spread out mass.
This M is actually
going to correspond
to basically the mass
contained within the orbit.
So using a formula like this,
given the mass distribution
that we see in the
Milky Way galaxy,
we can guess what
kinds of velocities
we should see various
things rotating at.
And we can plot that and we get
a curve that looks like this.
But we actually,
as we'll see later
when we go ahead and observe
what velocities stars are
really moving at, we'll
actually see a huge discrepancy
between what we would expect
from the visible matter
that we can see.
And basically the way that we
might be able to explain this
is possibly there is matter out
there that we just can't see.
And physicists term this
matter as dark matter.
So what we're going to be
working on in this experiment
is trying to be able to actually
plot this rotation curve.
And in being able to
show these discrepancies,
this will motivate new physics.
So how are we going to
find this rotation curve?
So the way we're
going to be looking
at the velocities
of various stars
is using the Doppler effect.
In our case, this will be
a non-relativistic Doppler
effect.
This is simply
just, as an object
is moving towards
you, the frequencies
that it emits are
slightly higher than if it
were standing still.
So we can look out at the stars.
But looking for
optical light doesn't
work too well because
it suffers absorption
from other stars or
interstellar gas and dust.
So instead we prefer something
in a slightly lower frequency
range around the
radio emission range.
Luckily for us,
hydrogen actually
exhibits an emission
in this lower frequency
range, particularly, yeah,
at this 21 centimeter line.
And this occurs as
spin flip transition.
So when the proton
and electron go
from being aligned
to anti-aligned,
that's a slightly
lower energy state,
and so it releases a
little bit of energy.
And we can look at that
energy coming from the sky.
And by seeing how
that frequency shifts,
we can deduce the
velocity that the emitter
must have been moving at.
So this is the
apparatus we're going
to be using for detecting
our various emissions.
The actual telescope
itself is a parabolic dish,
which takes an incoming
light, reflects it
onto this feed horn,
and the net signal
is fed into this
fairly complex circuit.
I'll just point out
some important things.
The signal comes in,
it gets amplified,
goes to the bandpass filter.
That's just to get rid of
any frequencies we absolutely
don't care about.
And then one important
point is that it goes
to this image rejection mixer.
And what that does is it
multiplies the incoming signal
by a signal that we manually
put in of 1420.4 megahertz.
That's the frequency of
the 21 centimeter line
that we're looking for.
And as you can see from
this trigonometric formula,
multiplying two
signals is actually
equivalent to just producing
one signal whose frequency is
the sum and one
who's the difference.
And by using the
second bandpass filter,
we can eliminate
the sum and just
be left with this signal,
which is the difference.
And so the reason
we do this is just
to get a very precise
measurement of how
off the signal we're seeing
is from the 21 centimeter line
we would expect from
a still observer.
And using that we can figure
out what velocity the emitter
is moving at.
OK, and so in order to
turn this into temperatures
is what we'll be dealing with.
We're going to first
have to calibrate
this with a noise diode.
What this will do is just
send a signal to the feed horn
that looks like 115
Kelvin blackbody all
throughout the sky.
And so it uses the signal it
sees from this to extrapolate
other signals that it will see.
So basically, if
later on it sees
a signal that's twice as
strong as the signal that's
on its calibration, at some
specific frequency then
it says, oh, there must
be a 230 Kelvin blackbody
at that specific frequency.
So at the end we'll
be getting some sort
of temperature profile as
a function of frequency.
And we're going to be
taking measurements
all across the galaxy.
Essentially, our galaxy is
mostly shaped in a planar disk,
so we'll be just looking
within that disk.
The galaxy has some central
bulge with some spiral
arms coming out of it.
And our sun is
located down here.
We will be sweeping from the
galactic longitude of zero,
which is directed towards
the center of the galaxy,
out to 180, which is
directed away from it,
so we'll be looking at the
first and second quadrants.
As we'll talk about later, these
first quadrant measurements
will be used to determine
the rotation curve
and the second
quadrant measurements
will be used to determine
the structures of the galaxy.
OK, so as we mentioned
before, given a frequency,
we can turn that into a
velocity using our Doppler
shift via this formula.
This 120.
4-- or 1420.4 megahertz is just
the emission, the frequency
of the 21 centimeter line.
This right here is just
the speed of light.
And then we have this VLSR.
This is just our velocity
with respect to the sun
just to factor
out any revolution
that we have around the sun.
So this V observed is actually
the velocity with respect
to the sun, not with respect us.
And so now we can use this
velocity using various trig
formulas, Law of Sines.
We can relate the velocity we
observed to the actual velocity
of the star in question.
And note here we have to
use this critical assumption
that the stars move in
circular orbits, which
is fairly close to accurate.
But using this
assumption allows us
to say that the
velocity of this star
is at a right angle
with its radius.
And then if we know the
radius at which the star lies,
then we can use this formula
to relate the velocity we see
with the velocity of the star.
And here we're going to
be taking R naught, which
is the distance from us
to the center of the sun,
to be a 8.5 kiloparsecs
and theta naught,
which is our speed
within the galaxy,
to be 220 kilometers per second.
These numbers are
not too well known,
but these will be the
values we'll be using.
And the literature
will compare again,
so we'll be using
the same values.
Right, and so this formula
is all well and good
if we actually know what
radius this star is at.
But, a priori, we
don't know that.
So the trick we're
going to be using here
is actually just to consider the
maximum velocity that we see.
And the maximum velocity will
occur at the minimum radius.
And that's simply given
by this R naught sine L.
And so if we specifically
consider that minimum radius,
then this formula allows us to
relate that maximum velocity
to the velocity of
the star in question.
Note, however, that
this only works
for longitudes less than 90.
That's in the first quadrant
I was talking about before.
And that's simply
because, if you're
looking at stars
which are further
away from the center
of the galaxy, then
they're all just going to
get further and further away.
There's not going to
be any minimum radius.
Right, so we wanted to determine
this maximum velocity that's
equivalent to determining
a minimum frequency.
So how are we actually going
to get that minimum frequency?
So as we said before, we have
this temperature spectrum
as a function of frequency.
We're going to start off
by trimming off the edges.
There's just a
very quick falloff
just from the
bandpass filter there,
so we have to get rid of those.
And at each given longitude,
we take about 40 trials
and we average that into one
the temperature spectrum.
So this is what our
spectrum looks like.
We're going to fit the first
few bins to a linear background.
And we can see that the
background fit is quite
good for these initial points.
You'll notice here we have
this annoying little peak here.
This actually shows up
in most of our plots.
This is probably because of
just some constant source
that's creating noise.
So when we fit this background,
we just ignore those points
in particular.
But for the rest of the
points, the fit is quite good.
Then we're going to find
the first point, which
exceeds this background by
some fixed amount one Kelvin.
And we say that that is going
to be our minimum emission
frequency.
So in this case, this
is 1420.4494 megahertz.
And we can estimate the
error on this method
by basically fudging
this 35 number,
so see what happens
if we use the first 20
bins versus what happens when
we use the first 50 instead.
And so the number
we get out of it
will shift a little bit
up or a little bit down.
In this case, it shifted one
bin up and two bins down.
And so that gives us an error
on what this kind of method
will give for a minimum
emission frequency.
And by default, if shifting
around this 35 number
doesn't change
anything, then we'll
just say that the error is
just the bin with itself.
Great.
So using that minimum
mission frequency,
we can find a velocity
as per the formulas
I had a few slides ago.
And we can also get
the radius simply
as a function of the
galactic longitude.
And we can plot it out.
And we'll get a curve that
looks something like this.
So this red curve
that I'm plotting here
is a curve I found in the
literature from a paper
by Clemens.
He fit a piecewise polynomial
to his observed data,
and so we're
comparing it to that.
We see actually that the
later values, the higher radii
actually agree quite
well with the literature.
We see a little
more disagreement
with the lower values.
This can be for
possibly a few reasons.
One could be you might have
seen in that plot I had before
that the temperature
starts to rise much slower,
and so it's harder to find
an emission frequency.
For these higher values,
there's a much sharper jump.
Secondly, the actual
frequencies that you
need to move these
points up to this line
tend to be outside of
our frequency window
or where that annoying
little noise was, so that's
just somewhat of a
limitation of the apparatus.
And then the third is the
circular orbit assumption.
For smaller angles
this assumption
becomes more critical, and so
even a small shift in angle
can make a much
bigger difference.
So we see, if we look
just at the later points,
we actually get a pretty
decent chi squared of 13.4.
So, yeah, this agrees fairly
well with the literature.
So then there's one
more thing that we
want to try to look at using
this 21 centimeter line,
and that's going to be the
galactic structure of the Milky
Way.
As we talked about
before, we know
that the Milky Way
has spiral arms,
so we're going to try to see
if we can look out and find
those structures.
So in order to do
this, we specifically
need to assume some sort
of galactic rotation curve,
so we're going to be
working with the one
that we found in Clemens.
And using the
formulas before, we
can use this given curve to
solve for a specific R given
any observed velocity.
So now we can associate
radii with all the velocities
that we see.
And, of course, this
is just the radius
from the center of the galaxy.
What we actually want
is the distance from us
in order to be
able to plot this,
so we can make that
quick change here.
And now note that
this only really works
for galactic longitudes
greater than 90.
Those are things in the
second quadrant simply
because, if we look inwards
to the first quadrant,
there are two
possible solutions.
Along the same line
of sight you can
find two different points
that have the same distance
from the center.
And again, we're going to fit
these to a linear background
now with 25 initial
bins and 10 final bins.
And we're going to
say the temperature
above the background
multiplied by the distance
from us squared,
this is just because
of an inverse square
power law, we're
going to say that that gives
us a relative measure of how
much hydrogen must be there and,
as a result, how much emission
that we're seeing.
So we can use these methods
and plot out of a big plot
of what the second quadrant
of the Milky Way galaxy
looks like.
So you can see here, there are
two spiral arms we can see,
one much closer to us and then
one forming out around here.
Those actually correspond fairly
well with this Perseus arm here
and then the outer
arm further out here.
You might notice that, as we
get up to higher longitudes,
the points start
to become larger.
Here the points denote
the strength, yeah,
the relative amount
of hydrogen that we
would see in a region
out there based
on the temperature
of the background.
And so you might see
here that, as we get out
to higher longitudes, we start
to see it blow up a little bit.
We don't believe that this
is a physical consequence,
that this is actually physical.
This is more just a
limitation of the apparatus.
So in conclusion, we were
able to use this 21 centimeter
technique to derive the
rotation curve of the Milky Way,
and we saw pretty good
agreement with the literature
for large radii.
In particular, we saw there was
a constant velocity function
as we went out to
higher radii, and that
disagrees with the
theoretical prediction.
And so this really
necessitates some sort
of dark matter, which can
compensate for the discrepancy.
We were also able to see some
of the Milky Way structure
by looking at the
exterior points.
And in particular, we
saw two spiral arms
in that second quadrant.
And finally I would like to
thank my partner, Toby, for all
his help throughout
this semester
and on this particular
experiment, some last minute
data collection.
I'd like to thank the 8.13
staff for all their help
throughout and
instruction and then MIT
for offering this course.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Questions?
SAARIK KALIA: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that you fit your background
to a linear fit.
SAARIK KALIA: All right.
AUDIENCE: Why do you
expect the background
to go up as you go in frequency?
It seems like, at
least [INAUDIBLE],,
it would just stay constant
across all the planes.
SAARIK KALIA: So I think this
is essentially because of the--
you would expect the temperature
that you see from a blackbody
to go like Planck's Law
or his formula, right,
the blackbody spectrum formula.
But essentially
what we're doing is
we're zooming in on a very,
very small part of that,
specifically around
one frequency.
And so in that
region, it's linear.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SAARIK KALIA: So this
is why we're expecting
some sort of linear background.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Good questions?
SAARIK KALIA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What uncertainty do
you find in your temperature
counts?
Or is there uncertainty?
SAARIK KALIA: So for the
rotation curve, the uncertainty
in the--
I mean, yeah, I guess there
should be some like Poisson
uncertainty in the
temperature counts.
For the rotation
curve, that's not
as important
because what we care
about is the frequency
at which it occurs.
I guess for the
galactic structure,
you really could put
some uncertainty on that
and it would just be squared
of n Poisson uncertainty.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And no other questions?
Thank the speaker again.